hey Gary this is ian Western man from
essential tennis calm I've got a quick
question for you for ask Gary Vee first
and foremost though thank you so much
for what you do it was six years ago
that I was commuting an hour in each
direction to a job back in forth
listening to crush it and that book
fired me up so much so my question for
you is when you play tennis or at if
you're still playing tennis now do you
see parallels between tennis and
business and being successful in either
one or in both what what are those I'd
be really curious to hear your thoughts
great great question you know it's
really interesting to me tennis is game
I love a lot and I've recently figured
out how not good i am because i've met a
lot of private school kids rich kids who
play tennis a lot and we're on the
college tennis team and so i love the
game and i like playing the people that
give me good 6-4 7-6 6-2 kind of matches
in both directions and i have a lot of
fun with and I like it a lot and as a
matter of fact I really do see one
parallel and I've never thought about
this before and this is really why I
love the askgaryvee show King you know I
I i do see a parallel I'm blown away
that I once lost a match that I was
winning 5-0 in a set and I'm also super
happy can somebody get Nate Zach can you
get me uh this is me fun I'm also happy
that you know and you've heard me talk
about halftime adjustments right on the
coach they'll be down 21 nothing and
then it's 23 21 and I won because I
didn't game playing well but I adjusted
that to me is tennis right to me tennis
is fascinating cuz the set is very long
and you can be down 30 and then you're
adjusting you're seeing patterns for
example yeah mate is it true is it true
that you've never beaten me and tennis
unfortunately yes now is it also true
that you once had me down for two you've
had me like help me here you've had me
down 52 twice you right and you lost
those matches
okay so what I did in those matches were
that was at thanks bro so in those
matches when I was down 52 to Nate what
happened was you know one I just like
refused to lose but to I really kind of
took a step back look that what happened
in those first seven games and started
attacking either weaknesses of his or
strengths of mine it's a very mental
game I was reacting to what was already
happening in that specific set and I was
able to adjust in a win 75 much to my
happiness and so much like in business
people set out to do things it's kind of
like the Mike Tyson quote right
everybody's got a plan until they get
punched in the face you know that's what
I see in tennis and that's what I see in
business you have your business plan you
think you're going to succeed and then
you're out in the market and somebody
copies your product for less or is
better than you or nobody really wanted
your stupid app you've got a just and in
tennis cuz it's a set it takes a lot of
time to that that kind of like set to
like form and you've gotta just wait a
minute he's playing off of his back here
let me go app his backhand things of
that nature let me go to the net because
I'm not winning this baseline game the
adjustments in real time and the emotion
and composure and the intestinal
fortitude to be down 52 and come back
and win that's how I see